oK we've got nearly 7,000 of our viewers
and listeners now regularly
participating on our subreddit a
subreddit is like a discussion forum
except instead of living on our website
it's on Reddit you can access it by
going to david pakman.com slash re d di
t some interesting discussions that
started in the last couple of days that
i noticed this morning that i want to
point to here is one I emphatically
support David's opinion regarding people
shaming Trump cabinet members
non-violently in public settings the
only thing necessary for evil to triumph
is for good men to do nothing voting
them out takes time protest is what we
can do now are you feeling Pat at all
influenced by what has happened in the
last 48 hours to say you know what maybe
the public shame campaigns are a good
thing well to be clear I'm all for
protesting I'm all for being aggressive
I just don't think that we should
intimidate people harass people you know
deny them service go to people's homes I
think there's a middle ground between
these two positions if would your mind
be changed if an elected official was
advocating for the death penalty without
trial of political opponents would it
then be okay to go to people's houses
and play sound of kids crying and bother
them at restaurants yeah I mean I like
the sounds of kids crying I think that's
an effective strategy to protest but I
guess I mean is would you feel
differently if you felt that the problem
was more serious if there could be a
place where the Trump administration is
doing something that goes too far right
and then it would maybe it's it's a
matter of drawing a line so in reality
you actually aren't opposed to the
tactics you just don't think it's gotten
bad enough to warrant the tactics at
this time I'll go with that for now wow
that may be even scarier prepare for a
flood of hate mail for producer Patrick
Ford or maybe people agreeing with him
maybe people agree with that okay also
from the david pakman show subreddit
youtube introduces channel memberships
merchandise and premieres yeah we are
part of the youtube sponsor beta and
what YouTube has determined is that
they're going to keep YouTube's
sponsorship but they're gonna rename it
as a channel membership so it's going to
be the exact same thing if you currently
are a YouTube sponsor for $4.99 a month
you will just be grand
in to the channel membership program I
people already started emailing me Pat
saying wait I became a youtube sponsor
now YouTube sponsorship is getting
canceled and I've got to sign up for
this other thing called the channel
membership and the answer is no no it is
the same thing it's just a name change
that's all so don't worry too much about
it
also from the david pakman show
subreddit if you could travel back in
time to post World War One Germany and
your mission was to stop fascism from
rising how would you do it you know very
often people say I'd kill Hitler but I
have a different approach what about
just taking Hitler and putting him in a
particularly because the focus is on not
using violence as the threat starter
since bonus points for not using
violence put Hitler in a more nurturing
environment which would probably have
prevented him from doing what he
ultimately did get him into that art
school he was rejected from that's
exactly change the course of history
that's exactly right and sometimes we
have this idea of history as this we
look back at history as if this was the
only and inevitable course just by sheer
math if you think about three of the
major sort of dictators of the 20th
century in Mao Hitler and Mussolini
there's a 50/50 chance of a child being
born a woman versus being born a man
roughly speaking it's not exactly 50/50
but it's close enough that means that
the odds of Mao Hitler and Mussolini all
being born men is about 12.5% that means
that there was an 80 7.5 percent chance
that one of those three was born a woman
dictators are almost exclusively men so
merely by something that was not that
likely it was only a 12 and a half
percent probability that you end up with
those three dictators history could have
much very easily gone a different way
and I think it's important to remember
that when we think about history as this
inevitable path it's the path that came
by chance and often even by very small
probability had two ways to look at that
I guess one is that we could have
avoided having to deal with those
dictators altogether by chance the
there is that who which dictators did we
miss out on because the channel being
born didn't happen yes and if you meet
some of the folks in my family you would
say had this person been born a man they
would have been a dictator we really
dodged a bullet because they weren't no
names no names okay last thought from
the David Brin show subreddit what is
David writing during phone calls yes so
we actually had a cancellation today for
our interview so you will see me doing
this later when we take calls I will be
making notes
I basically write the caller's name in
three dimensional block letters that's
what I do I'm a piece of paper just it's
my I don't have time to do any artistic
stuff so as I listen to the callers I
write down their names in block letters
and shade them in 3d with very specific
light placement that's all I'm doing on
my piece of paper I thought you were
doodling over there but apparently not
no no I'm paying very varistors maybe of
what you think the caller's look like
yeah that would be an idea and then
after the call I hold up a picture of
the caller that I've drawn that would be
something join the reddit at david
pakman.com slash re d di t